hello there how many languages do you
speak
es
espanol
palettes
you know
all too often in the anglo-saxon world
the answer is i speak one language i
think that's rather unfortunate
i think people today
can and should speak three or four or
more languages
you know the languages of the world are
divided into
families of languages but two families
account for about two-thirds
of all the language speakers in the
world
the largest group is the indo-european
language group that has about 45 percent
of the people in the world and the
saino tibetan which includes chinese
group has another 22 percent so that's a
lot and in my experience if you can
start learning one language in a family
or better still one in each of those two
families you have a good chance of
learning other languages of that family
and that's been my experience i made an
investment
in french and then in chinese mandarin
chinese when i was in my late teens and
early 20s and from that base i've been
able to learn
right now a total of 10 languages and i
haven't stopped i intend to continue
and one major reason why i want to
continue
is that language learning is one of the
most useful self-improvement activities
that you can undertake
research has shown that language
learning is very very good for brain
fitness for your memory
for staving off
alzheimer's
you're constantly forced to create new
patterns in your brain as you struggle
to get used to new languages
but language learning should be a
pleasant activity
all too often
in our schools language learning is made
to be an unpleasant activity people
dislike learning french in school or
whatever other language they have to
learn but that's not how i learn
languages and i talk about that at my
blog thelinguist.blogs.com
when i learn i just do pleasant things
because the more pleasant the
association i have with the language the
better i learn so i listen i read
i've even developed a system for
learning words and phrases and for
associating pleasant thoughts and
pleasing context with those words and
phrases and i talk about this at my blog
but the main thing is you have to have
an attitude
of
wanting to enjoy the language believing
that you can do it
accepting the language and you'll be
surprised at how well you can learn and
the benefits are enormous
i know there are people who are involved
in pilates and yoga
and mountain climbing and all other
kinds of activities
that they hope will improve their mind
and their body
and that's all well and good
but i would vote for language learning
as being the most beneficial activity
that you can engage in because not only
do you end up with an increased ability
to communicate with your fellow human
beings you also train your brain
and the whole experience can be
extremely enjoyable if it's done the
right way so once again this is steve
kaufman here
i hope to see you at my blog
thelinguist.blogs.com
now let's see we can say audra adios
and
it's not just a matter of showing off
with a few phrases it's a matter of
enjoying the fact that you can
communicate comfortably with people of a
different culture and i have done that
for much of my life traveling to
different countries and it has helped me
not only socially but also in my
business so once again
why don't you come to visit my blog and
also take the plunge and learn another
language